[Music]
on this Monday night high altitude
mystery what we know and don't know
about those objects shot down over
Canada and the U.S the RCMP is obviously
considering both the Yukon and the Lake
Huron events as matters of National
Security Canada's role in the search for
debris plus what the Chinese government
is saying
inside a Turkish Hospital filled with
earthquake survivors
the staff working tirelessly to help and
heal and an explosion caught on camera
the destruction and injuries in an
Ottawa neighborhood
[Music]
thanks for joining us pressure is
intensifying to explain a series of
objects shot out of the sky over the U.S
and Canada there are many theories but
few answers except that the first one
was according to American authorities a
Chinese spy balloon here's what we do
know on February 4th a flying object a
suspected Chinese surveillance balloon
was shot down off the coast of South
Carolina after flying over Canada and
across the U.S six days later a second
object described as the size of a small
car and flying at forty thousand feet
was shot down off the coast of Alaska on
Saturday a third object described as
smaller and cylindrical was shot down
over Yukon by an American fighter jet
and on Sunday a fourth object was shot
down over Lake Huron in Michigan
described as being like an octagon with
strings hanging off it and flying at
about twenty thousand feet the last
three were shot down even though
authorities say they don't know what
they were Canadian authorities are
working to recover the debris in Yukon
and Lake Michigan they held a briefing
late today and China has accused the U.S
of flying spy balloons over its
territory more than 10 times since
January of last year claiming the U.S
routinely gathers Intelligence on China
it is a tense topic and has put North
American surveillance systems on high
alert Mackenzie gray has our top story
tonight
U.S fighter jets over Michigan Sunday
afternoon just minutes after shooting
down another unidentified object this
one was first picked up on radar over
Southern Alberta it's now believed to be
at the bottom of Lake Huron on the
Canadian side we will do our very best
to secure this material so that we can
understand better what the purpose and
the operations are about another
operation underway in Yukon but with a
massive search area covering mountainous
and snowy terrain no debris has been
found from Saturday's missile strike on
another UFO it really needs to be the
Canadian Armed Forces leading the
recovery efforts because we as I've said
we don't know the degree of Hazard that
could be involved Canadian officials
admitting the recovery effort might not
be successful right now we are working
very hard to locate them but there's no
guarantee that we will the incidents
just two or four recent shoot Downs by
U.S fighter jets the Downing of that
Chinese spy balloon near South Carolina
the only one the White House has opened
up about publicly these three we don't
have attribution for right now we don't
know we don't know who owns them but
despite no confirmation of where they
came from the Prime Minister believes
there's a connection between all four
obviously there is some sort of pattern
in there the fact that we are seeing
this uh in a significant degree over the
past week is a cause for uh interest
Justin Trudeau didn't elaborate on what
the pattern could be but the defense
department did offer more details I
think the the best word I can use here
is a suspected
it's it's clearly objects that are
lighter than air we cannot see any
propulsion system these smaller hearted
attract threats pose a new challenge to
NORAD which could lead the alliance to
make changes we just haven't had to
defend North America against balloons
before so this is relatively new there
are still many unanswered questions
about the various objects but we did get
guidance today from the White House on
one key Point Donna they ruled out that
any of the UFOs were from Aliens
well that's been a good news Mackenzie
gray and Ottawa thanks for more insight
on this our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is with me Mercedes there are
a lot of missing pieces in this story
spy agencies in all countries are in the
business of of course concealing
intelligence and information how much do
you think is really known about these
objects but is not being revealed to the
public
well certainly more than we're hearing
Donna for example the pilots that shoot
them down as their flying past would be
performing something called a visual ID
that means they're looking out the
window they're trying to come up with
descriptions and there's likely
photographs and videos that have not
been released to the public it's one of
the things the Canadian officials were
asked about today and they wouldn't
commit to releasing those images so that
people could see what these look like
that could be part of an effort to try
to protect whoever's putting these in
the air from knowing exactly what Canada
knows although I suspect that they have
some sense of what's been shot down they
also will have been monitoring these
objects to see whether they're
transmitting are they transmitting on a
certain schedule are they transmitting
Communications equipment and what kind
of a payload are they carrying we've
heard that they're in at least a couple
of the cases including the one over
Yukon is a payload visibly being tied
below what is that and what does it do
part of those questions are only going
to be answered when they're able to
actually recover the technology and
that's very sensitive as you heard is
the Canadian Special Operations forces
who are up there to do what they call
sensitive site exploitation this could
be toxic or radiological material when
they're recovering it and they've got a
wide area before even they will know
exactly what they're dealing with but
Donna an interesting thing about this
whole bit they have to discuss it in
public which isn't something I'm sure
that they really like normally this
would be happening behind closed doors
normally we'd probably never hear about
it um Mercedes prime minister Justin
Trudeau said there is some sort of
pattern here he said that today is he
hinting at something or what have you
heard from your sources about what these
objects are
well I mean there's clearly a pattern of
things floating in the sky that are not
supposed to be there that no one can
explain all of the sources I've talked
to describe these as suspected balloons
and we keep hearing officials kind of
slip and say that as well and then
correct themselves and say suspected
balloons they're floating objects at
this point so the question really is
what are they doing up there who put
them there and and what more can they
find out other than they appear to be
moving from west to east and going back
and forth between Canada and the United
States so it could be that these are all
part of a global surveillance program
being operated by China which my sources
have told me balloons from that have
crossed Canada before and they may have
in fact have retrieved previous balloons
but at this point the only pattern we
have is that they are weird things in
the sky that there's no explanation for
in Mercedes it was an American fighter
jet that shot down the object over Yukon
in Canadian airspace some people wonder
why it happened that way can you explain
the point of NORAD the North American
Aerospace Defense command
yeah so it's designed to allow either
Canadian or American jets to get where
they need to go as fast as possible and
that means that Jets from each country
can fly in the other in fact on 9 11 it
was a Canadian who was in command in the
U.S who would have made the call to
shoot down American civilian airliners a
much more significant decision than
shooting down an unmanned balloon so
this is actually how the command is
supposed to work the ultimate Authority
for whether or not a shot is taken
belongs to the political head in that
country which is why it was Justin
Trudeau who authorized it but this is a
very rare bi-national command where
Canadian and American assets operate
equally all right Mercedes Stevenson
thank you
Canada's premiers say they will accept
the health care funding deal offered by
the federal government but they're not
happy about it prime minister Justin
Trudeau met with the premiers last week
to pitch a plan to inject about
46.2 billion dollars in new money to the
provinces and territories over 10 years
in a statement Manitoba Premier Heather
Stephenson says the premiers welcome
more Health Care funding but she says it
does not address the long-term stability
and the challenges of the Health Care
System she says the provinces will work
with Ottawa on a longer term plan
in turkey and Syria conditions for
survivors of the earthquake so rapidly
deteriorating and the U.N warns the
final death toll could double more than
31 thousand people in Turkey are known
to have died rescue efforts in some
areas are called off excavators have
been brought in to remove debris Aid has
been slow to reach many in turkey with
limited shelter and no food some are
sifting through Rubble to retrieve
whatever they can to survive
and in Syria the official number of debt
has topped 4 600 millions of people are
displaced there have been protests about
the lack of humanitarian Aid the un's
head of emergency relief says the rescue
phase is coming to a close he says the
world has so far failed syrians today
Syria's president said he would open two
further Crossing points on the Turkish
border to allow in more Aid
now the humanitarian phase the urgency
of providing shelter psychosocial care
food schooling and a sense of the future
for these people that's Our obligation
now
not all rescue teams have given up some
are still finding Signs of Life beneath
collapsed apartment blocks
Quakes a 13 year old boy was pulled from
the debris in Turkey he clung to his
rescuer's hand as he was put on a
stretcher and then into an ambulance
turkey's hospitals are overwhelmed with
the injured Jackson prosco visited the
largest regional hospital in southern
turkey where he met some of the youngest
survivors
Adana City Hospital is near capacity
most of the 1600 beds are filled with
patients injured in the earthquake
here we met four-year-old ilay she was
found under the rubble with her mother
after more than 80 hours
her grandmother told us they were
brought here by helicopter
then she showed us the severe burns on
ilay's Tiny body her mother is being
treated in the same Hospital ilay still
hasn't been told her father and brothers
are dead
words do not suffice her grandmother
said the family's apartment building in
the city of antakia collapsed like a
house of cards the developer was
arrested by Turkish authorities while
allegedly trying to flee the country
we have nowhere to go other than the
hospital she said incredibly the
hospital did not suffer any damage
that's because it was new and built to
withstand earthquakes up to magnitude 9
but the same could not be said for the
homes of many of the doctors and nurses
they like their patients have nowhere to
stay
through the busy corridors we were taken
to the office of the medical director it
was packed with anxious surgeons and
Specialists
said his staff are working around the
clock many sleep in their offices we
asked what keeps them going
he said it's the constant sound of
helicopters and ambulances bringing new
patients that includes at least 50
Anonymous children found by themselves
too young to know their own names
may not be alone but she is deeply
shaken and will need care long after her
visible wounds heal
Jackson prosco Global News Adana Turkey
the latest Russian offensive in Ukraine
has begun according to NATO's Secretary
General Russian forces are pushing
towards the eastern city of bakmut
Moscow claims it's already taken a
nearby settlement NATO's Yen stoltenberg
says the military Alliance will increase
supplies of ammunition he's urging
Ukraine's allies to ramp up their
Military Support Canadian instructors
are helping train Ukrainian troops on
tanks in Poland the capture of bakmut
would give Russian forces a new foothold
in the Donetsk region after several
months of setbacks Global News will Air
a special on February 25th to mark one
year since the full-scale Russian
invasion of Ukraine more than 70
thousand people participated in protests
in Jerusalem today demonstrators say the
governments plan to overhaul the
judicial system in Israel is a threat to
democracy and could weaken the courts
I'm protesting for my children I'm
processing for this country I'm
protesting for the country my father
fought for critics say the plan would
give prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
greater control over the Supreme Court
and give his cabinet veto Powers he says
the changes are necessary to restore
balance protests like this have been
taking place for weeks across Israel the
country's president Isaac Herzog gave a
prime time address on television warning
the absence of dialogue is tearing
Israel apart from within and he said the
country is on the brink of
constitutional and social collapse
a rude awakening in an Ottawa
neighborhood
[Music]
two people have been found alive in
Ottawa in the rubble of a construction
site after a gas leak triggered a major
explosion
he was caught on a doorbell camera the
people were taken to the hospital in
serious but stable condition 10 others
were treated for minor injuries it
happened in a neighborhood where several
homes were under construction tariya
isri has more on the investigation
a Housing Development is now a mountain
of debris after a powerful early morning
explosion jolted people out of bed I was
in a deep sleep and all I hear is Boom
felt like a truck just ran into the
house I wake up go check on my little
girl she's only four months old a gas
leak triggering the blast wiped out four
homes under construction and trapped two
men beneath the wreckage one of our
first Crews here they cut through a lot
of debris with chainsaws rescued them
out
the second man was inside a pre-built
home that collapsed he was stuck in the
rubble for three hours until
firefighters freed him the blast was so
extreme that people that didn't even
reside close to the site felt it so um
you know there was a lot of concern
initially of just you know what was that
was it an earthquake was it an explosion
we're all considering it a bit of a
miracle that nobody was killed given how
extreme the blast was the explosion was
so strong it caused damage across the
street it buckled this garage and next
door smashed a window pane it was just
this huge shake and it was it was it was
pretty scary because it was just for a
good five or so minutes all you just see
is this debris flying around
doorbell cameras captured the moment a
ball of flames shot into the sky
this man's windows are blown out and
part of his roof is caved in one of
dozens of homeowners now dealing with
damage a little bit inside of the house
shifted backwards and then came back but
then the drywall split away from the
from the wall exactly you see it
separating
an army and Red Cross are helping those
forced out of their homes in a blast
that set off a wave of panic caused
destruction and sparked many questions
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
not done yet ahead why Toronto's mayor
is still in office after announcing his
resignation last week
[Music]
Toronto's Mayor John Tory is resigning
he said so on Friday after it became
public he had an affair with an employee
but he's not leaving just yet Toronto is
in the midst of budget deliberations and
Tori wants to see that through Global's
Matthew Bingley is at Toronto City Hall
tonight Matthew
Donna when Toronto's mayor appeared late
Friday to announce that he was resigning
he avoided using two key words effective
immediately and now we've learned that
Tori will stick around to see his budget
through
the office of Toronto's mayor is no
stranger to a gaggle of reporters
waiting outside but the John Tory era
was able to avoid it until now I
developed a relationship with an
employee in my office in a way that did
not meet the standards to which I hold
myself as mayor and as a family man
Tori's admission to an affair with a
staffer in his office came with a
guarantee his time is Mayor would end
early but he offered no timing on when
that will happen complicating when an
upcoming by-election will take place the
only way that a member can step down and
resign is to actually file written
notice with the clerk don't believe
that's happened once that happens then
the clerk must put the uh the
resignation at the next council meeting
as counselors carried on meetings with
the mayor some were Keen to see a
reversal of the resignation we've just
got to make sure that we give Assurance
to the public that it's a time of
stability that coming together and uh
and look he's done a lot of great things
for the city and he can make a graceful
exit this Wednesday Council will have to
approve a budget which under new
provincial legislation ended strong
mayor Powers is officially the Tory
budget I don't think you should stick
around I think basically he said he's
resigned and it just complicates things
the mayor's office says Tori has held
meetings with senior leadership to
discuss an orderly transition of power
the timing of which won't be revealed
until after that budget meeting another
complicating Factor are those strong
mayor Powers which can't be transferred
to the deputy mayor and will create
difficulty for future city business
City council's budget meeting was always
bound to be a contentious one as the
mayor's Rivals attempted to make changes
to it now with the guarantee that John
Tory will actually be there this meeting
will take on an entirely different tone
Donna okay Matthew Bingley at Toronto
City Hall thanks
exploring the mystery next are we in a
new era of high altitude surveillance
balloons
[Music]
that four objects floating at high
altitude were shot down in 10 days over
North America is extraordinary but
balloons like this are not entirely new
high altitude sophisticated balloons or
airships are being developed by several
countries including the U.S and China
until now they have mostly flown under
the radar Tonight Eric Sorensen takes a
deeper look at what's being done to try
to detect them
they just shot it what is going on up
there first an alleged Chinese spy
balloon and now more objects have been
brought down over North America with
Canada right in the middle of it the
Chinese balloon suggests there's a new
era in surveillance to gather data that
satellites high above cannot obviously
the closer you are to something the the
more detail you can see so a balloon
would have that as an advantage it has a
certain amount of what we call
persistence to stay over a particular
region of the ground below you you can
Garner information on radio waves on
Cyber activities and things like this
that not necessarily a satellite would
be able to to be able to sense many of
the satellites we know for weather and
Communications are way out about 35 000
kilometers and in sync with the Earth's
orbit most satellites however are in low
earth orbit up to 2 000 kilometers above
the Earth there are some 2 800
satellites including spy Satellites by
comparison the International Space space
station orbits around 350 kilometers
above Earth now outer space begins
around 100 kilometers up commercial
aircraft fly around 10 to 12 kilometers
high weather balloons are often in the
stratosphere that Chinese balloon was
determined to be about 60 kilometers
high the other objects brought down over
the weekend were 20 and 40 kilometers
high it's in this space between where
commercial aircraft are flying and where
outer space begins that objects have not
been watched as closely and that is
changing one of the reasons that we
think we're seeing more is because we're
looking for more the White House
concedes that the U.S Canada and NORAD
have only recently begun to tweak their
radar systems to watch that airspace for
objects slower than planes and missiles
they have modified the filters and the
gains as we call it of the of the radar
capabilities to look more
discreetly at high altitude small radar
cross section and low speed objects
it'll be important to find the objects
to know whether they're all designed in
some way to test North American defenses
these are going to be very key
operations not only in getting answers
for Canadians but being able to prepare
to counter future threats there are few
answers but many new questions about how
intelligence is being gathered over
Canada and the US and how to prevent it
without shooting down more and more
unidentified aerial phenomena Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is blind Bay British Columbia
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]